for
centuries no human has had the power to
become a monster
until now behold the transformation ray
awesome but is this safe though let's
find out
[Music]
is everything okay down here hey drac
what's up
johnny oops
[Music]
what's going on i used van helsing's
transforming ring
dad you're human drag oh no
i have a total dad bod
um what is going on huh
look at you now look at me what's up
who are those guys it's me uncle griffin
you don't recognize me
i literally never seen you before
we need to find a way to fix this there
is a place
deep in the amazon only there can the
transformations be reversed
time to go
[Music]
wow flying his monster is so much better
right
you're not a vampire the sun won't fry
you now it's glorious
it's wondrous
it's burning my eyes
if we don't fix you guys soon you'll be
like this forever
seriously everybody relax just enjoy the
view
ah please being a human
is the worst and swim
and relax yeah mosquito
can't fly
hotel transylvania transfer mania
boy that was fun the only place to
experience transfer mania is in a movie
theater october 1st